PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, what
we'd like to do
is find the volume
of a paraboloid--
this one that I've drawn
on the board-- using
what we know about Riemann
sums and integrals.
And so, this paraboloid,
just so you understand,
what we do is we take the
curve y equals x squared
and we rotate it
around the y-axis.
And we're looking in
particular, from height--
the height of capital H,
so from 0 to capital H,
that's what our y-value
is ranging over.
And what we'd like to do
is find the volume enclosed
by the rotation of y equals
x squared around the y-axis.
So what I'd like you
to do is to think
about how you could write
the volume as an integral.
And I would suggest
that you think
about integrating in the
y variable as opposed
to the x variable.
So we're going to do
it in the y variable.
So I'll give you a little
while to think about that.
Start as a Riemann sum,
take it to an integral,
and then I'll come back
and show you how I did it.
OK, welcome back.
So again, what
we're trying to do
is find the volume
of this paraboloid.
And we're hoping to write it
as an integral in the end.
So I'm going to give us a
little understanding of how
we start the process.
And what I want to do is break
up this paraboloid first,
into our first-best guess.
And I'm going to estimate the
volume using four different--
I'm breaking it up
into four pieces,
so I'll use four cylinders.
So let me actually just
draw these cylinders.
So I'm going to start
at the top radius.
And that would maybe
be my first cylinder.
And then the next radius
would be the one down here.
Actually maybe I
can alternate color.
You'd be able to see
them a little better.
The next radius would
actually be this one kind
of right here coming around
that way, going down,
so it sticks out a
little bit from there.
Let me just kind of
shade that lightly.
And the next one is
using this cylinder.
So that's our diameter here.
And then the last one-- well,
that doesn't look very even.
But we'll just say
that there are four.
To keep it with four,
I'll say the last one
is starting right here.
So I don't have to
draw any more pictures.
And the last one
is that cylinder.
So there are four
cylinders here.
This one comes around behind.
There are four cylinders here.
There's the blue one here,
a white one, a red one
and another blue one.
And I can actually estimate
the volume of this paraboloid
by finding the volume
of these cylinders.
So we have to
understand how to find
the volume of the cylinders.
And then what we'd like to do
is to get better approximations,
we're going to make
these cylinders flatter.
So we're going to
make them not as tall.
And then as they get flatter
and flatter and flatter,
we're going to get better
and better estimates
of the paraboloid's volume.
And then in the
limit, we will get
the volume of the paraboloid.
So this again should
remind you, this
sounds a lot like Riemann sums.
What we've been doing
with Riemann sums.
You're adding up--
you're estimating area
under the curve, in
the case that you've
seen mostly in class.
But maybe this reminds
you of the volume
of the pyramid problem that
you saw on the lecture videos.
So it's very similar
to that idea.
Now let's figure out how we can
write this sum of these four
cylinders in terms of y.
So what do we need to do?
Well, first we're going
to designate the height
of the cylinder as delta y.
That's the change in y.
That does not look like a y.
Let me try that again.
Delta y.
OK.
So each height-- and even
though it doesn't look like it,
we're going to say that
they're evenly divided.
So let's make, in your mind
this one should be a bit bigger
and this one should
be a bit smaller.
So delta y is going
to be a constant.
And then I have to
figure out the radius.
Right?
Well, we know that at height y
the radius squared is height y.
Right?
r squared equals h.
So what I actually need is that
at height h, or at height y,
the radius is square root y.
Right?
So at height y radius
is the square root of y.
So when I want to look at
the volume of the cylinder
at height y-- I'm using the
upper value here-- so at height
y, what is the volume
of the cylinder?
We know in general the volume
is equal to pi r squared h.
And so, the height here
of the cylinder-- this
is not the height
on the whole thing;
this is the height of
that individual cylinder--
the height of the
cylinder is delta y.
And r is square root y.
So r squared is just y.
So the volume of a single
cylinder is pi y delta y.
So again, we find the
volume of this cylinder
by taking the y-value
here, multiplying it by pi
and then multiplying
it by delta y.
And I do that for this one, this
one, this one, and this one.
And then I add them up.
And that's my estimate of the
volume of the whole paraboloid.
So now what can I do?
Well, again, I mentioned we can
divide into more subintervals.
And let's say we
only divide-- let's
say we divide it into
n subintervals. right?
What would this look like?
I'm going to be
taking a sum to find
the volume of the whole thing.
I'm going to take a sum
from i equals 1 to n
of these kinds of things.
Pi y sub i delta y.
So each y sub i represents the
y-value at the different height
where I'm taking my cylinder.
Now delta y, in this
case, if I divide
into n equal subintervals,
delta y is H divided by n.
And then you can actually figure
out the y sub i's from that.
The first one would be H over n.
The second one would be 2H over
n and so on until the top one
would be H*n over n and you'd
have H as the top height.
So those are the values
that we're ranging over.
And now, as we let
n go to infinity,
this is our Riemann sum.
This is actually going
to be an integral.
Delta y goes to dy.
And let's look at what happens.
So we get dy here.
We're going to have an integral.
And what are we
actually evaluating?
We're evaluating the
function pi y at what places?
Well, as delta y goes to
0, the first value of y
sub i that I get is
pushing down to 0.
And the last value we know is
H. So we're actually taking
an integral from
0 to H of pi*y*dy.
And that is the
integral representation
of the volume of the paraboloid.
Now this is a very easy
thing to take an integral on,
so you could actually
evaluate this and find it.
I believe you'll get something
like pi y squared over 2 from 0
to H. So you should
get something
like pi over 2
capital H squared.
You can check my math, but
I think that's correct.
So that is actually the volume
of the paraboloid carved out
by this particular
curve, y equals
x squared, from, or
at height capital H.
So that's where we'll stop.